han sido mutiladas sexualmente de esa manera.
En algunos países, es más del 98 %
de las mujeres que son mutiladas antes de llegar a la madurez.
Esta es una aflicción terrible
para todas las mujeres que viven en esos países.
Otra cosa muy seria son los crímenes de honor,
donde una familia malinterpretando de nuevo, una escritura sagrada
--no hay nada en el Corán que mande esto--
ejecutará a una niña en su familia
si ella es violada
o si se casa con un hombre que su padre no aprueba,
o, a veces, incluso si ella viste ropa inapropiada.
Y esto es practicado por los miembros de su propia familia,
por lo que sus familiares se convierten en asesinos
cuando la niña trae la así llamada deshonra para la familia.
Naciones Unidas no hace mucho hizo un estudio en Egipto
y mostró que el 75 % de estos asesinatos de una niña
son perpetrados por el padre, el tío o el hermano,
pero el 25 % de los asesinatos son cometidos por mujeres.
Otro de los problemas del mundo
en relación a las mujeres es la esclavitud,
o la trata de personas como se llama hoy en día.
Unos 12,5 millones de africanos fueron vendidos como esclavos
en el Nuevo Mundo entre los siglos XVIII y XIX.
Hoy viven en esclavitud 30 millones de personas.
El Departamento de Estado de EE.UU. ahora tiene un mandato del Congreso
para hacer un informe cada año,
y el Departamento de Estado informa que se venden 800 000 personas
a través de las fronteras internacionales todos los años como esclavos,
y que el 80 % de los que se venden son mujeres,
como esclavas sexuales.
En EE.UU. en este momento,
60 000 personas viven en esclavitud humana.
En Atlanta, Georgia, donde se encuentra el Centro Carter
y donde doy clases en la Universidad de Emory,
son vendidas como esclavas entre 200 y 300 mujeres cada mes.
Es el lugar número uno de la nación en este aspecto.
Atlanta tiene el aeropuerto más activo del mundo,
y también un alto número de pasajeros que provienen del hemisferio sur.
Si el propietario de un burdel
quiere comprar una niña que tiene la piel de color marrón o negro,
pueden hacerlo por USD 1000.
Una chica de piel blanca cuesta varias veces más que eso,
y el propietario medio de burdel en Atlanta y en los Estados Unidos ahora
puede ganar alrededor de USD 35 000 por esclavo.
El comercio sexual supera al tráfico de drogas en Atlanta, Georgia.
Este es otro problema muy grave, y el problema de fondo es la prostitución,
porque no hay prostíbulo en EE.UU.
del que no sepan las autoridades locales,
los policías locales, o el jefe de la policía, o el alcalde y demás.
Y esto crea uno de los peores problemas
que es que se compran cada vez más mujeres como esclavas sexuales
en todos los países del mundo.
Suecia tiene un buen enfoque al respecto.
Hace unos 15 a 20 años, Suecia decidió cambiar la ley,
y las mujeres ya no son enjuiciadas
si se encuentran en esclavitud sexual,
sino que son procesados
los dueños de los burdeles, los proxenetas y los clientes
-- (Aplausos) -- y la prostitución ha bajado.
En EE. UU. contamos con el método opuesto.
Por cada hombre detenido por comercio sexual ilegal,
se arrestan 25 mujeres en EE. UU.
Canadá, Irlanda, ya mencioné a Suecia,
Francia, y otros países se dirigen hacia el llamado modelo sueco.
Esa es otra cosa que se puede hacer.
Tenemos dos grandes instituciones en este país que todos admiramos:
nuestro ejército y nuestro gran sistema universitario.
Ahora están investigando
cuántas agresiones sexuales ocurren en el ejército.
En el último informe que tengo,
un total de 26 000 agresiones sexuales tuvieron lugar en el ejército...
26 000.
Solo 3000, un poco más de un 1 %, son procesados en realidad,
y la razón reside en que el oficial al mando de cualquiera de estas
--una nave como mi submarino, o un batallón del Ejército
o una compañía de la Marina--
el oficial al mando tiene derecho por ley a decidir
si se debe procesar a un violador o no,
y, por supuesto, lo último que quiere que se sepa
es que bajo su mando, ocurren agresiones sexuales,
por lo que no los procesan.
Esa ley tiene que cambiarse.
Cerca de 1 de cada 4 chicas que ingresan a universidades en EE. UU.
serán agredidas sexualmente antes de graduarse,
y esto ahora tiene mucha publicidad,
en parte debido a mi libro, entre otras cosas,
por eso ahora, 89 universidades de EE.UU. han sido condenadas
por el Departamento de Educación bajo el Título IX
porque los funcionarios universitarios no están cuidando de las mujeres
y protegiéndolas de la agresión sexual.
El Departamento de Justicia afirma que más de la mitad de las violaciones
en los campus universitarios son perpetradas por violadores en serie,
porque fuera del sistema universitario,
si violan a alguien serán procesados,
pero en un campus universitario pueden violar con impunidad.
No los procesan.
Ese es el tipo de cosas que ocurren en nuestra sociedad.
Otra cosa muy grave relacionada con el abuso de mujeres y niñas
es la falta de igualdad de retribución para un mismo trabajo, como saben.
(Aplausos)
Y esto es a veces mal interpretado, pero para un empleo a tiempo completo,
una mujer en EE. UU. ahora gana un 23 % menos que un hombre.
Cuando fui presidente, la diferencia era del 39 %.
Así que hemos progresado, en parte porque yo fui presidente, etc.
(Aplausos) (Risas)
pero en los últimos 15 años no ha habido avances,
la diferencia ha sido de 23 o 24 %
en los últimos 15 años.
Estas son cosas que suceden.
Si nos fijamos en el top de las primeras 500 compañías de la revista Fortune,
solo 23 tienen CEOs mujeres
entre las 500,
y esas CEOs, no hace falta que les diga,
ganan menos en promedio
que los otros CEOs.
Bueno, eso es lo que pasa en nuestro país.
Otro problema con EE. UU.
es que somos la nación más belicosa del planeta.
Hemos estado en guerra con cerca de 25 países
desde la Segunda Guerra Mundial.
A veces hemos tenido soldados luchando en tierra.
Otras veces, ha sido por aire
arrojando bombas sobre la gente.
Otras veces, por supuesto, ahora, tenemos drones que atacan a las personas, etc.
Hemos estado en guerra con 25 países o más
desde la Segunda Guerra Mundial.
Hubo cuatro años, no voy a decir cuáles,
en los que no lo hicimos...
(Aplausos)
no tiramos una bomba, no lanzamos ni un misil,
no disparamos ni una bala.
Pero de todos modos, ese tipo de cosas, recurrir a la violencia
y la mala interpretación de las Sagradas Escrituras
son la causa principal del abuso a mujeres y niñas.
Y hay una causa última que no hace falta mencionar,
y es que, en general, a los hombres no les importa un bledo.
(Aplausos)
Es verdad.
El hombre medio que piensa levantarse en contra del maltrato a las mujeres y niñas
acepta en silencio los privilegios que le brinda la posición que ocupa,
y esto se parece mucho a lo que yo sabía de niño,
cuando existía la idea de separados pero iguales.
La discriminación racial existió 100 años y fue legal,
desde 1865, desde el final de la Guerra entre Estados, la Guerra Civil,
hasta los años 60,
cuando Lyndon Johnson consiguió aprobar
los proyectos de ley para la igualdad de derechos.
Pero durante ese tiempo,
aunque hubo muchos blancos que no creyeron en la discriminación racial
se quedaron callados,
porque gozaban de privilegios como mejores puestos de trabajo,
acceso exclusivo a los jurados,
mejores escuelas y todo lo demás,
y lo mismo ocurre hoy en día,
porque al hombre promedio no le importa en absoluto.
Aunque dicen: "Estoy en contra de la discriminación contra niñas y mujeres",
gozan de una posición privilegiada.
Y es muy difícil eliminarla, dada la mayoría de hombres
que controla el sistema universitario,
el sistema militar,
los gobiernos del mundo
y la mayoría de hombres que controla las grandes religiones.
Entonces, ¿qué es lo fundamental que tenemos que hacer hoy?
Yo diría que lo mejor que podemos hacer hoy
es que las mujeres en naciones poderosas como la nuestra,
o de donde vienen Uds.,
Europa, etc., que tienen influencia y tienen la libertad de hablar y actuar,
asuman la responsabilidad
y exijan con contundencia
que se ponga fin a la discriminación racial contra niñas y mujeres
en todo el mundo.
La mujer promedio en Egipto
no puede decidir mucho sobre la mutilación genital
de sus hijas, etc.
Ni siquiera quiero entrar en detalles.
Pero espero que a raíz de esta conferencia,
cada mujer aquí presente obre para que su marido entienda
que existen esos abusos en los campus universitarios y en el ejército, etc.
y en el futuro mercado de trabajo,
y que tiene que proteger a sus hijas y nietas.
Tengo 12 nietos, 4 hijos, y 10 bisnietos,
y pienso a menudo en ellos
y en la difícil situación a la cual se enfrentarán en EE.UU. también,
y no solo si vivieran en Egipto o en un país extranjero,
en la igualdad de derechos,
y espero que todos se sumen a mí
en ser defensores de mujeres y niñas del mundo
y en proteger sus derechos humanos.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)